Okay, Jason from Maryland, appreciate the
phone call.
Thank you so much.
Let's go next to, where do we want to go next?
Why don't we go to, um, let's go to our caller
from the six, seven, eight area code.
Who's calling today from six, seven, eight
[inaudible]
Oh, that's me, Mo.
Hey ma, what's going on?
[inaudible]
he's doing well.
So my question is kind of the same as the
guy that called them before.
And it's about, I feel like a lot of people
who follow alternative media have this, uh,
we underestimate the power of mainstream media.
And cause I noticed that with my friends and
family, a lot of us, a lot of them have their
perspective and perception of politics completely
determined by what is stated on popular news
and that be so basically what I was thinking
about is that most people do not consume a
news intelligently and they're just passive
viewers of news.
So it's just background.
My best background noise.
So I would just wondering that because of
all this misinformation that when I talk with
my friends about politics, I noticed that
the discussion is very minimum and they tend
to use a lot of talking points to handle issues.
And I feel like they're kind of useless agents
of the status quo because the talking points
you here don't really dig any deep onto topics.
There's no nuance in discussion.
So I would just a wondering that you feel
that like since you have a big following that
you could mobilize your base to have people
come out and be go for like news reform kind
of like you have people who are going out
and advocate for electoral reform.
Yeah, I mean, listen, I am trying to do this.
So like earlier this week when we did a story
about the testimony of the us Envoy to Ukraine
and it just, it's an argument over whether
what the guy says is credible.
I took two thirds of the segment and I said,
you know, let's understand what, what different
people mean when they say there's no evidence
of a quid pro quo.
And trying to explain that the Republicans
are using the word evidence in a different
way than what it actually means.
And unless you understand this stuff and configure
it out for yourself, you're sort of going
to be reduced to only pick a talking point
that you like, which is basically what I hear
you saying.
So there's a couple of different issues here.
One is we can't really expect people to have
a more nuanced and deep understanding of an
issue if all of the inputs they get are equally
shallow.
Corporate media gives them shallow inputs.
Politicians often have an equally shallow
understanding of the issues.
So unless someone understands how to get a
deeper understanding of issues, again, by
learning critical thinking and epistemology,
then by actually reading in depth about some
of these issues, it's unreasonable to expect
the average person to have a deeper understanding
than all of the inputs that they are being
informed by.
So that sort of number one, you got to an
interesting point at the beginning though,
which I want to address, which is that there
are people who are in the independent online
media space who don't understand the power
that corporate media still has.
And you see, you know where you see that really
clearly when you hear from an Andrew Yang
supporter or a Tulsi supporter who say, I
don't think any of these polls are right.
Don't people realize how much support these
people have online?
They are going to win the nomination.
And it's like, no, no, no, no.
You are in an enclave where it seems like
Tulsi Gabbert has huge support or Andrew Yang
has huge support and yet they keep polling
between zero and three and it's not an attack
on the candidates.
It's just that a lot of people seem to be
missing that most Americans are busy enough
with their lives that as you say, they have
corporate news on often in the background,
they are not even considering candidates other
than the top candidates.
I'm not praising that, I'm just pointing it
out.
And I think that there is a disconnect that
is taking place and people aren't understanding
that most people's views are still primarily
informed by the talking points that you get
on mainstream corporate media and you, and
you seem to be identifying that Mo
[inaudible].
Yeah, and I noticed that cause when I talk
to people about Andrew gang and other politicians,
I mean other candidates that are running that
aren't as mainstream.
There really isn't that much recognition or
knowing who these candidates are.
And so I feel like a lot of people, especially
when they vote, they fall for it.
It narrative of voting for who was electable
and who could be Trump versus actually looking
at their policy and having a real opinion
that they can support.
And then one last thing I want to [inaudible]
I mentioned is whenever I talk about policy
with people, and I mentioned hoping that might
raise taxes or involved government intervention.
As soon as people hear that they think socialism
and then they tend to react to strongly a
negative because they don't wait, they're
not really thinking deeper.
So I realized that until we can have conversation
and news media can just present information
without a spin involved, most people are just
going to say, Oh, I've heard a lot of negative
things about socialism.
The media does a good job of, you know, creating
that negative association.
So when people here to work, they just react
strongly without actually really thinking
about it.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean a lot of people who have an opinion
about socialism don't even know what it is.
And you can be against socialism and be informed
or be against it and be uninformed.
And obviously we're much better off if people
are informed in their opinions.
Mo, I appreciate the phone call.
Thank you so much.
Points.
Uh, all, uh, all well-made.